[Music]
on this Monday night something to sink
your teeth into oral health is Health
expanded Federal Dental Care who's
eligible what's covered what's not
Palestinians pushed into Southern Gaza
fears of an exodus into Egypt while in
the West Bank violence from Jewish
settlers is on the rise I will stay here
even if they kill us CP 28 controversy
is the environment conference on the
cusp of complete
failure and the long arm of artificial
intelligence so the the hand will know
just to grab that's right a Canadian
company transforming
Prosthetics global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us we begin with news about an
expanded Dental Care program that will
help millions of Canadians who don't
have private dental insurance about 9
mill million people will eventually be
covered under the federal government's
plan older Canadians can apply next week
and it will be expanded to a wider group
next year though there will be an income
threshold for those that are that
qualify it would mean that your bill
will now be paid for by the federal
government and your your cost will be
free the NDP who pushed for a national
Dental Care Program are calling this the
biggest expansion of Public Health Care
in Generations Abigail ban has our top
story on who is eligible and what will
be covered sometime like I can't um
cover everything so that's why like it's
uh extremely uh difficult for me this
man is one of millions of Canadians with
no dental insurance today the government
unveiled details of the new plan
expected to cost $13 billion over 5
years when people don't have access to
dental care as I mentioned they have to
go to an emergency room that costs
millions of dollars in order to be
eligible you have to be Canadian
resident with no private insurance your
net family income needs to be less than
$90,000 a year and you need to file your
taxes eligible seniors 87 and older will
receive a letter this month and be able
to apply by phone in the spring an
online application portal will open with
everyone eligible able to apply by 2025
a wide range of services are covered
including cleaning X-rays fillings and
Dentures implants crowns and caps are
not dentists can voluntarily apply early
next year and have to build a program
directly for reimbursement Dr Amanda
Campbell doesn't think that will be a
barrier we frequently see
patients who come in and we can give
them some antibiotics or some medication
to deal with their symptoms at the time
and and we don't see them again
afterwards Dental Care is one important
pillar of the NDP liberal deal with the
new Democrats taking credit today for
the idea they've pushed for years we
have forced this government to take
action but there are some concerns the
Ontario Dental Association points to a
shortage of thousands of dental
hygienists and assistants Holly Von is
one of them she's about to leave her
hygienist position and has seen many
others do the same especially during the
pandemic and if there's not enough
support staff then people can't access
it anyways so I really hope that there's
initiatives so that the dentists can can
really you know in their heart see that
it's so important then there's the
question of the provinces many of which
have their own low-income dental
programs will those be cut while the
federal health Minister says all
conversations have been productive and
about augmenting existing Services
Alberta tells Global News it was calling
for a different plan to enhance existing
coverage instead it's now reviewing the
announcement and Saskatchewan says no
final decision has been made Abigail ban
global news Ottawa two years after the
federal government reached an 8 billion
class action settlement with with First
Nations living under drinking water
advisories Canada's indigenous Services
Minister has tabled legislation to set
drinking water
standards the law provides all of the
tools necessary for First Nations to
have the inherent control but also a
active partner in the government of
Canada to ensure that First Nations have
the resources they need to deliver that
water in a safe way and a sustained way
for generations to come the legislation
aims to protect freshwater sources and
create minimum drinking water and
Wastewater standards on First Nations
the government had repealed a previous
Safe Drinking Water Act introduced by
the conservative government of former
Prime Minister Steven Harper which was
considered unsustainable and an
infringement of indigenous rights Global
News has learned the federal government
will soon unveil its latest strategy to
address the housing crisis it involves
the creation of a housing catalog plans
that would be available for Builders to
use across the country with the
intention of making the construction
process move faster Mackenzie gray is in
Ottawa breaking down what's being
planned well Donna wartime housing like
this is a fixture across Canadian
neighborhoods and the trudo Liberals are
hoping to use the same Playbook to deal
with the current housing crisis here
over 2,000 houses have already Arisen in
less than a year and that pace is kept
up from the early 1940s until the late
'70s hundreds of thousands of homes were
constructed Architects and draft from
pre-approved building plans made
available for $10 by the Canada housing
and morgage Corporation a senior
government Source tells Global News the
federal government will announce
tomorrow that they intend to revive that
scheme The Hope standardized plans will
help speed up the zoning and permitting
process municipally leading to faster
building times yeah absolutely it could
take them uh over 12 months on the
project the system is in a crisis Mike
Moffett advised the federal cabinet this
summer to bring back this exact
initiative yeah I think Builders and
developers would be quite interested in
this particularly if it helps FasTrack
through the approvals process Builders
like 720 modular are particularly
interested they construct homes indoors
then deliver them to the job site
standardized plans could help them
reduce cost and increase production in
order to accelerate housing if we can
move to a standardized framework all of
a sudden now we have a fighting chance
to accelerate housing because we're not
having to redesign every time we go and
build a building even with this latest
proposal experts like mof at Warren it
will take at least 2 years Donna before
they impact the Canadian housing market
okay McKenzie gray in Ottawa thank you
Kenneth law the mississaga man accused
of selling so-called suicide kits is now
facing more than a dozen murder charges
related to multiple deaths in Ontario
law was charged today with 14 counts of
second deegree murder that's in addition
to the 14 counts of aiding and abetting
suicide he was already facing connected
to the same victims police alleg law
operated websites that sold a lethal but
legal substance and other items that can
be used for self harm investigators
believe law sent at least 1,200 packages
to people in more than 40 countries and
he's at the center of multiple police
investigations Advocates and family
members of victims linked to serial
killer Robert pikon her outrage the RCMP
has applied to destroy thousands of
pieces of evidence collected during the
investigation they believe it could be
relevant in other cases including those
of missing and murdered women and girls
getting rid of that evidence destroys
all chances we have for future cases and
cold cases in Canada this latest step by
the RCMP to seek disposal of all
exhibits a mere 20 years after the
investigation on the farm began sends
the message that the missing and
murdered women's cases are closed
despite the majority of them being
unsolved pikon was found guilty in 2007
on six counts of first-degree murder and
the deaths of women who disappeared from
Vancouver's downtown east side the RCM
he says all relevant evidence has been
retained and police aren't authorized to
keep property indefinitely Israel's
defense minister says the Army will take
any measures to destroy Hamas in Gaza
but has no intention of staying there
after 66 days of Israeli bombardment
gaza's Health Ministry run by Hamas now
says more than 18,000 Palestinians have
been killed nearly 50,000 injured since
October 7th the United Nations says 1.9
million people across the territory are
now displaced from their homes that's
more than 85% of the population Israel
claims the last Hamas strong holds are
on the verge of collapse it says it's
targeting three areas two regions in the
north and one in hunis that's the
largest city in the South there is no
safe place and thousands of Palestinians
have been pushed South towards Egypt as
Crystal ganing explains Israel is
accused of laying the groundwork for the
mass expulsion of gazin into Egypt
it's life on the
Run what have they done to live in these
conditions asked this woman is she holds
a child while sitting in an ever
expanding refugee camp in
Rafa Israel Defense Forces told
civilians if they want to live they need
to go south since those initial warnings
nearly 2 million people have moved again
and again in search of
safety I think that what has happened to
us was planned thinking they can
displace us from the Gaza Strip to Egypt
therefore Palestine would cease to exist
there was an Israeli government draft
relocation plan leaked in October that
suggested moving gazin south eventually
into Egypt and then onto settlements in
the Sinai desert while it was dismissed
by Israeli officials after it surfest at
least one politician Jordan's foreign
minister is voicing his fears that
that's that's exactly what's happening
what we see in Gaza is not simply uh the
killing of of innocent people the
destruction of their of their
livelihoods but we are seeing uh a
systematic effort it seems to empty Gaza
uh from its people as the bombings and
urban combat continues Israel's
government spokesperson rejected the
Jordanian foreign Minister's assertion
calling it
outrageous Israeli officials say their
fight is with Hamas
not civilians those managing to survive
in the midst of the conflict are barely
hanging on people lack absolutely
everything a special un Envoy is in
Egypt examining what can be done to get
more Aid into Gaza and have it safely
distributed to where it's needed a task
that's growing increasingly complex and
dangerous Crystal Ganson Global News
London Israel's war on Hamas is is
making headlines but there is also a
significant rise in violence on the
occupied West Bank a recent Human Rights
Watch report says settler violence has
doubled since October 7th Danielle hamam
Jin visited a small Palestinian Village
to talk to people about the attacks by
Jewish settlers attacks they believe are
aimed at pushing Palestinians out and a
warning her story contains graphic
images we're in the South Hebron Hills
in the West
Bank the small village of susia is home
to 35 Palestinian
families but this is not the original
susia over there says Muhammad hammad a
few hundred meters away that's where
they were driven from in
1986 and ever since then Israeli
settlers have tried again and again to
push them
[Music]
out house demolition are a constant
sight in Palestinian Villages around
here harassment is part of everyday
life here are the settlers taking over
the susia playground with the Israeli
military doing nothing to stop them
what's unique about this Village is that
it's entirely surrounded by Israeli
settlements and the Israeli military and
since October 7th they've restricted
movement in and out of the village
in the past two months the Palestinian
death toll across the West Bank has
surged killings at the hands of both
Israeli forces and settlers say
Palestinian authorities I will St here
even if they kill us we want to live in
our land this is our land they took all
our lands and they closed all the
village around us they plowed our land
they prevented us from picking our old
trees
there zot is a far-right lawmaker who
oversees an Israeli parliamentary
committee on the West
Bank he says settler violence doesn't
exist that it's a media fabrication so
you don't accept the fact that sometimes
the IDF does nothing and just
watches not everything is perfect he
says there's crime everywhere including
Canada residents of susia tell us the
settlers often dress in Israeli military
uniforms as cover on our way out we
cross paths with three young Jewish men
who would normally be wearing that
uniform if not for their refusal to
serve they now spend their days sleeping
in these Villages documenting violence
against
Palestinians this can no longer exist
that this is situation that is uh
putting many people in danger putting
all the Palestinians in danger of
getting killed of being in prison of
being uh
under uh under control every every
single day the US has now imposed Visa
bans on Israeli settlers engaged in
violence against Palestinians a rare
move by Washington the EU is now also
considering it as for Ottawa there is no
official policy yet but the immigration
Minister says people who commit crimes
of this nature shouldn't be welcome in
Canada Donna Danielle Hamin in Jerusalem
thanks is Parliament about to lose
another speaker coming up why there are
calls for Greg Fergus to quit after just
two months on the
job less than three months after the
last Speaker of the House of Commons
resigned the liberal MP who replaced him
is also facing calls to resign Greg
Fergus is Accused by the opposition of
engaging in partisan politics and
betraying the neutrality required of
those who sit in the speaker chair David
Aken reports on the committee now
considering his future boy did we have
fun this is the offending video uh
through the Ottawa South liberal
Association uh through Liberal Party
politics by helping D mcy get elected
wearing his speaker robes while standing
in the speaker's office Greg Fergus made
a tribute video to another liberal
politician that even his liberal
colleagues concede he should not have
made speaker made a video is it
inappropriate yes was it a misuse of
parliamentary resources
probably Fergus said he had no idea the
tribute would Air at the recent Ontario
Liberal Party leadership convention
Fergus thought it was for a private
party regardless of it being aired
privately or publicly I should never
have recorded it I apologize
unreservedly I know I messed up and I
won't do it again big deal but saying
sorry may not be good enough for members
of parliament to continue to to trust
his judgment is just asking too much the
correct thing for Mr Fergus to do for
the Integrity of the position he holds
and for the house itself is to
resign the bla feels the same the NDP
has not yet settled on a redy and the
Liberals while they seem ready to
forgive and tighten up training
procedures for any future speaker I
don't know about you but I think every
single one of us in this room has made a
mistake in their life it's what we do
with it as for Fergus he has given no
intention that he is going to resign
instead he'll wait for the verdict from
the procedure and house Affairs
committee which will be tabled in the
House of Commons as early as Wednesday
Donna okay David aen in Ottawa thanks no
mention of fossil fuels ahead why
critics call the UN climate conference
grossly
[Music]
insufficient there's uproar on the
second last day of the UN climate
conference in Dubai a draft agreement
does not contain any direct mention of
phasing out fossil fuels an apparent
concession to oil producing countries
like Saudi Arabia that oppose it it was
a key Demand by the European Union and
many developing countries especially
vulnerable to climate change because
they're opposed to the fossil fuel
language they're trying they're trying
to block negotiations on just about
everything else and that's very
unhelpful um and and and for parts of
the world life thre in climate Advocates
Fear The Summit could be on the cusp of
complete failure the draft agreement
contains watered down language saying
countries could reduce the use of fossil
fuels more than 100 countries including
Canada are calling to phase them out
entirely countries in climate activists
are slamming the draft the US is calling
for it to be strengthened well the eu's
chief negotiator calls it clearly
insufficient the summit has until
tomorrow to produce a final
agreement an activist group is
condemning in the United Arab Emirates
for conducting a mass trial of detainees
on what they're calling fabricated
charges the Emirates detainees Advocacy
Center claims the country is trying 87
prisoners many of them human rights and
democracy Advocates on multiple
terrorism charges if convicted they
could face life in prison or the death
penalty this would Mark the second
largest mass trial in the country's
history a world's first next the
Canadians who created a bionic arm
powered by a
I I'm
just the Golden Globe nominations are
out and Canadian Ryan Gosling is in the
running for best supporting actor for
his portrayal of Ken in the movie Barbie
the box office hit has 10 nominations
including Greta Gerwig for best director
the second highest number of nominations
in Golden Globe history Canadian writer
and director sine song is recognized her
debut movie Past lives hailed as one of
this year's best films earned
nominations for Best Director and best
Motion Picture drama while Canadian
musician Robbie Robertson is up for best
original motion picture score honored
after his death for his work on Martin
scorsese's killers of the flower
Moon well we may not fully understand
the potential of artificial intelligence
but it's already part of our Lives it's
being used to revolutionize research and
business and in the F of artificial
limbs it is shrinking the difference
between what's real and what's
prosthetic Mike drle
explains you have to fight it great grip
it's not the Terminator but smart arms
grip is impressive nonetheless this
prosthetic is less about power than it
is about dexterity and intelligence
artificial intelligence to be precise so
the the hand will know just to grab
that's right
which is hard for a lot of people to
wrap their head around right from Canada
team smart armal chowri started smart
arm four years ago after beating out
50,000 other Tech inventors at a
Microsoft competition that's the trophy
up on the wall of his Toronto office he
emerged with a desire to build and
Market the world's first AI powered
prosthetic arm at an affordable price
regulatory approvals are still pending
but the hope is to have it on the market
next year which is remarkable in its own
right considering technology has only
recently caught up to the dreams of
inventors like chry 20 years ago they
saw that you know technologies will
never come together to be able to
fulfill what inventors said was going to
happen people do believe it augmentation
technology that's where we're going
after this chowri and his partner Evan
nef are doing it all here in Canada as
part of a burgeoning AI Community but
they're testing it with people from all
over including former NFL player Shae
Griffin the first time he actually put
on Smart arm and and interacted with it
we were sitting at a restaurant he was
picking up repeatedly and like picking
up and putting down a glass of water I
think it was at the time and and you
know he'd take a drink from it and he
he'd put it down he'd pick it up again
and like hand it to me or or uh Evan you
witness somebody who had never used
their left hand before used their left
hand yeah uh essentially
that'll blow your
mind that's the power of AI to disrupt
established Industries and products
while giving consumers a firm grip on
the future Mike trle Global News
Toronto and that is global national for
this Monday I'm Donna freezen tonight's
your Canada is La Grand rud de moral the
feris wheel in the Old Port we'd love to
see your festive Canada photos please
email them to viewers at
global.com and thanks for watching hope
to see you here again tomorrow
[Music]
bye-bye